aj i understand you grew up in ohio
yeah i grew up in the cincinnati area
just north actually west chester ohio so
you said you have a very
happy you have yeah my childhood was
awesome i had great parents thankfully
that's awesome
they were really supportive
when did you break the news to them that
you said mom dad i have somebody to tell
you i want to be a filmmaker i think
they figured it out when
my dad brought home a camera from he was
a professor at miami of ohio and so he
would periodically get a chance to check
out some of the gear from at the time of
the library i think
they had those one of those shoulder vhs
cameras and he would bring it home for
you know to record opening presents on
christmas or whatever it was that we
were doing family wise but i would steal
it and go make little films and
i think they figured it out pretty early
on that i was going to be interested in
that kind of thing so
so
this is what 1990
some yeah i was born in 84 so
my first film
i was eight so i was like 92 i think
and what are you editing on at that time
uh and the cameras back in the day they
had this little thing called edit button
where you would just basically rock her
back and forth and
get to where you wanted to start the
next edit and then you would have to
like basically have the person in mid
motion and start recording at the right
moment
and i would just edit in the camera i
never really did any
linear editing until maybe i was 15 or
16 years old when digital cameras came
out and they're a little more prevalent
and easily accessible
uh funding wise
um i worked at best buy so
when i was 16. i got
one of those cameras and i was like
oh man you can actually like
cut an imovie and do things in slow
motion i got a little slow motion heavy
for that for like a year or two after
that but
yeah it was neat to already have the
experience of
to me it was a luxury to have linear
editing at that point because you're
like oh man i don't have to like have
the person start where they were gonna
be
in the next shot and
looking back on it was pretty
complicated work that we were doing but
i also i think i figured out a way to
like hook my nintendo 64
up through into a cd player and then
split that into another vcr and then go
into another vcr and then add
soundtracks that was in in sound effects
we would play we'd do four player
goldeneye so we could have one person
being each person and controlling the
sound effects for the action scenes and
whatnot so so were you the kind of kid
that would take stuff apart so you could
see how it worked yeah put it back
together i did i
oh man my parents bought me like one of
these electronic
uh
i want to say erector set but it's not
it's something that real it's like a
basically a computer but
you hook it up with different wires you
can make it do different things i don't
know that really interested me when i
was very young i was probably like late
80s early 90s when that came out
and then
i remember one time i was in first or
second grade i took apart a
rotary telephone and hooked up a battery
to it and made it work like in class it
was pretty cool
so i was doing stuff like that all the
time when i was a little kid
a little engineering stuff i didn't
realize it was engineering though at the
time i look back on it now and i
realized that i i really enjoyed that i
kind of wish i went to school for
engineering because i'd probably be
able to
utilize that knowledge in the field of
film like designing cameras and stuff
like that now
what did you choose as your major
uh mass communications because it was
the closest thing to film
uh that they had at miami of ohio
and for the first year or two i didn't
really like it there because
i felt like i wanted to actually go to a
film school because at the time it was
sort of a big deal to go to film school
it was like people were you know it was
right after pulp fiction and
robert rodriguez is the world were
making their films and
becoming big successes
and uh
you know there were
there was a lot of
kind of hype about going to film school
at that time and i
i thought about it for a long time and i
think i wanted to do that just so i
could get access to the gear really
um to make more movies but
i read robert rodriguez without a crew
and i was like i guess i don't really
need to go to film school i could just
make my own films and learn from that so
that's kind of what i chose to do and my
dad also was like hey do you want to go
to college for free because i work here
or do you want to come out of college
with however much debt
and
no degree that anybody cares about i was
like well don't want the debt so
i uh
i
i made the most of my time at miami i
started a film society there and we were
able to get funds for a lot of neat gear
that wasn't available at the time
and it's actually still running today
there's a
pretty large
group of students that are putting that
are still keeping it going and they're
constantly getting new gear and staying
on the cutting edge of the technology
today so i go back there every now and
then and teach a class and
get to interact with those kids they're
great and they also come out here for
the summer and june actually they'll be
here for something called inside
hollywood
that was put together by some of the
professors that i work with there
and it's basically
a chance for students to come interact
with the alums from miami
and also just get a chance to see what
it's like to be out in la and and the
business side of things so they're not
coming out here with stars in their eyes
or come out here with like legitimate
ideas of what they want to do with
themselves
well speaking of which you showed us a
video of yourself when you were what was
it eight years old yeah well i was 12
actually oh 12 i'm sorry okay
and uh
you said something very interesting you
you were being shown with some like you
know movie music in the background you
said that you want to do this but not to
become famous
yeah
i uh i didn't
i didn't come out here to be famous
that's for sure i didn't want to be an
actor
or anyone that was like
you know
celebrity of any kind that's not
anything that interested me what
interested me was making movies
that people enjoyed and
i wanted to give people the feeling that
i felt when i watched movies that i
really liked like
some of my favorite movies back in the
day were predator terminator like those
kind of movies and i was
always super
emotionally connected to the characters
and because of that the action scenes
were like so intense and i felt like
it's you know a lot of intense emotion
from those films when i was watching
them i wanted to recreate that feeling
in my films and hopefully someday make
somebody else feel the same thing so
that was what drove me when i was a kid
making movies i wanted to do that stuff
and i could see it myself in my early
films like i would fill in the blanks
with all the crappy production design
and like
silly props and whatnot but i saw what
it really was supposed to be like
and i hoped one day that i could
make it really come to life
thankfully most recently i was able to
do that
at least to a certain extent on compound
fractures
right well so you knew from a young age
that you wanted to do this and your
parents it sound like
they were very supportive of whatever
endeavor you wanted to go into
how long did it take you to decide to go
to the school that your dad was at
versus
it wasn't really in my decision
ultimately well i graduated or high
school really
um as a junior
i had to convince my parents to let me
do that but uh
like i said
i felt like i knew what i wanted to do
pretty early on uh 14 or 15 years old i
was pretty committed to
pursuing film as a career
so high school
once you have a decision like that kind
of covered high school just feels like a
big play pen you're like here i am stuck
in this place because my parents
don't have anywhere to put me during the
day
i'll probably get in trouble if i don't
go to school
and have something else to do with my
life
uh really the main reason why i'm here
is doesn't feel like i should be here at
this age and i already know what i'm
suppose what i want to do with myself so
i wrote this like seven page essay to my
parents about why i should be able to
graduate
um i happen to have enough credits to
graduate except for like there was some
little half credit course that i needed
to take for i think it was english or
something like that
from before miami would recognize that i
had graduated
so i did whatever that was in the
summertime after my parents
agreed to let me do it
and so i started uh i started freshman
year i was 16 years old
at miami of ohio
and then
i carried on through there
graduated at 20 and then moved out here
to the itunes 21.